well we're joined Now by one of the
city's big names he is a chair of the
UK's biggest Supermarket Tesco and the
country's biggest house Builder Barrett
developments John Allen so really no one
better to speak to delighted to have you
on the program delighted to be here now
you're the chair of Tesco had pretty
good Christmas by all accounts um but
how hard are things for customers at the
minute well I think it depends on the
customer you know there isn't a
one-size-fits-all answer I think
customers are very Savvy they're working
very hard to find ways of alleviating
the impact of rising food prices so that
they can trade down they can use
different ingredients they can cook more
at home as opposed to going out
um but underneath that of course there
are a large number of people who really
are struggling to make ends meet and
we're very conscious of our
responsibilities not just to those who
shop with us but also those who can't
afford to shop with us which is why we
support a lot of food banks Charities
associated with that
Etc are you seeing a change then in
people's shopping habits I was
interested when you were talking about
people shopping more savly you know
value items being bought more of what's
going on yeah I think there's a whole
series of mini Trends but they include
people you know cooking more at home as
opposed to going out uh trading down for
Brands to own label we've been
advertising showing people meals simple
meals they can construct for a with
named ingredients and prices which are
on a per capita basis very low we've
been running ads telling people to check
what you've already got before you go
out and shop because you may be buying
things you don't need and that
contributes to food waste which you know
is massive still in homes but of course
there are people who haven't got fridges
stuff full of food you know and and they
need they need help it's really
interesting and to hear you say that and
what is happening with food inflation as
well because it's interesting with
inflation you have a headline rate but
then obviously you have what's going on
under the bottom if you like food
inflation but also particularly you know
some of those Staples as well yeah I
think look it we're not in the business
of making forecasts about food inflation
I did about a a year ago a bit over a
year ago and and more by good luck and
good judgment got happened to get it
right and I made a vow then that I would
have to get it right we want to hear
more of it no no no but I uh but that
was a fluke frankly
um I I my chief executive when he
announced our results last week said
that our Hope was that
um the peak of food inflation would
probably arrive around about the middle
of this year but frankly that's an
aspiration as much as a forecast and
um and that doesn't mean prices will
start falling it means they hopefully
will stop stop going up nearly as fast
so we haven't we're away off the peak
I think we've got some way to go to get
to the peak and then prices will still
probably continue to rise more modestly
but who knows you know and it's it's a
function of all sorts of things that are
beyond our control Energy prices what
happens in the Ukraine Ukraine harvests
and so on
um so we will see but you know we and
I'm sure other uh supermarkets will can
use strenuously to help our customers
cope you know with the fact that prices
are still going up for example we've
locked a thousand prices until Easter so
that's a thousand prices that people
know are going to be the same at least
until Easter it's a Russian exercise he
wants to halve inflation this year I
think that's achievable
I'm I'm not qualified to make that uh
the Judgment I mean it'd be wonderful if
it happened I think inflation will go
down but remember having inflation still
means price is rising at maybe five or
six percent which I think would seem
terrific in comparison with now but
prices would still be going up and if
you're on the red line that's still
getting harder for you indeed so I think
the uh I think inflation will start to
come down uh but just how much and when
I think I'm not brave enough to forecast
that makes sense
um just the final sort of forecast
question if you like and it was just a
soft one don't worry
um the economic growth thickers for
November which were released this week
we're actually surprising a lot better
than some people expected
um do you think that we should have a
Slither of optimism I guess that the
landing may be softer than we think well
I think a sliver but you know individual
months figures can be first of all they
get adjusted subsequently they don't
always end up the same as they start the
World Cup may have helped people were
you know buying large amounts of well I
was staying in and buying large amounts
of beer or whatever to to celebrate so I
wouldn't read too much into uh these
figures but one's hope would be that if
we do have a recession that it's a
relatively mild one and not too
prolonged but you know that's a hope
rather than the forecast we um have
talked a lot about inflation and what it
means to people's budgeting obviously
the big worry is that people's pay isn't
keeping up with inflation what's Tesco's
policy been when it comes to pay well I
think we had our normal pay settlement
in the you know first second quarter of
2022 we then realized it was racing
Rising inflation that wasn't adequate so
we had a second round negotiations with
our unions and our colleagues and we
ended up I think with a overall rise for
our colleagues on the shop floor
um of around eight percent last year and
we've told them that we will start this
year's negotiations earlier in fact in
the next couple of weeks so that if it
is necessary to make a further
adjustment and I don't want to
anticipate that we will be in a position
to do so so I think we think it's
important to keep up with events and you
know you mentioned my relationship with
Barrett barretts have done something
similar you know we've added extra
one-off payments to our people to
because you know if you are at the lower
end paid end of the spectrum this is a
cost of living crisis is a really tough
thing for people to get through it's
much easier for highly higher paid
people which is why both businesses I've
been involved with
um the price the salary Rises for
management have been low single digits
because the viewers they can afford to
they've got enough in the pot to be able
to cope with a rise that is below
inflation for a time I have to say the
contrast between Tesco and Barrett
revising and having settlements and
what's happening with the government
sticking with the pay review bodies
settlements
it's quite Stark
well yes I think I don't know if you
asked me to express an opinion on that
Sophie but I was giving the opportunity
well look let me start by saying I think
I mean Tesco is relentlessly politically
neutral we want to work with whatever
the government of the day is but you can
have personal views if I express a
personal view rather than the Tesco view
I think you know I think it would be
good and perhaps there are the first
signs of this happening or for
government to start engaging with those
groups of Public Service workers who are
currently unhappy because I think the
only way to settle this will be through
negotiation understood there's also
anecdotal evidence
um of people leaving jobs in the public
sector like care work or nursing and
coming to work in supermarkets where
they may feel that their pay is
competitive and the working conditions
are frankly better are you seeing that I
think a little bit I haven't got any
numbers but I know that you know
certainly people are leaving the care
system I think
um and heading towards other uh jobs
including supermarkets including Tesco
I'm not sure about nurses but uh you
know I think it's a it is a competitive
labor market and and that's something I
think those involved in these
discussions need to remain aware of I'm
Keen to talk to you uh with your uh
Barrett uh hat on as well because
there's been lots of uh concern about
the state of the housing market
um what's your assessment of where we
are well there's definitely a downturn
in demand at the moment
um I think the rise in interest rates in
the Early Autumn spiked rises in
mortgages and that's actually put people
off buying houses understandably this
happens from time to time in the the
house building Market the house builders
I think are perfectly capable of
weathering this storm we all tend to run
with strong balance sheets knowing that
every decade or so there will be a year
or two that are where there's a downturn
I think we'd like to see more government
support particularly for new uh you know
new home buyers first time home buyer as
and we would like to see some reform of
the planning system to make it easier to
build because the other thing it's
inhibiting the house building sector at
the moment is a planning system which
means you can't actually saw concept of
MPS blocking plan reforms well precisely
um but you know but I think the you know
the house builders are fit and strong
and will survive
um I'm concerned more about people who a
lot of people this year will face as the
end of fixed term mortgages come they
will face much higher mortgage payments
which will add another twist to the cost
of living crisis for for many families
do you think we're really Brave we're
really aware of just how difficult that
contract is likely to be
um I don't know I think it depends who
you're talking to I'm certainly aware of
it and I think it's uh it's going to
it's going to make life difficult for
many hundreds of thousands of families
uh each year as you know deals are come
to an end and revised and go up
significantly know the fact that
interest rates have abated a bit is
helpful yes so it's not as bad as it
looked in you know the Early Autumn and
do you think we'd like to see a fall in
house prices this year then yes yeah
okay to make a forecast and I don't like
to make them but absolutely not but I
think it would be very un you know it's
very unlikely there will not be some so
indeed there is some softening already
uh and I think if people go looking for
our houses or any of our competitors
they're all behaving very similarly
they'll find the sort of little
incentives to try to persuade them which
weren't there a year or two ago and I
think that's just understandable
Behavior okay it's been really
interesting to talk thank you so much
coming in this Sunday morning thank you